Hi there.
Today, I'm gonna talk about network monitoring with
one of my favorite tools,
Telegraf.
My name is David Mackay. I'm from Glasgow
in Scotland.
And I'm a developer advocate for a company
called Equinix Metal. You may be familiar with
their former name of Packet, the bare metal
cloud.
I'm a cloud native streamer, which just means
that I get to spend a large chunk
of my time on YouTube playing with cloud
native technologies and hopefully provide an educational materials
for us all to learn together.
And I'm a bit of a monitoring enthusiast.
I spend a lot of my time monitoring
systems and even things that aren't systems that
probably shouldn't be monitored. But,
you know, I've always been a number certain
person, and I love to get data out
of anything I can to make sure that
I'm on the right path. It's also worth
mentioning as a disclaimer that I was formerly
a developer advocate for a company called InfluxData.
You may be familiar with them as they
are the people behind InfluxDB and Telegraf itself.
And I think this is a good thing
that I'm still here talking about Telegraf after
my time at InfluxData.
I genuinely believe is a great product that
solves many many problems and we should all
be using it for something.
Now what about Telegraf? Well,
it is a plug in driven
collection agent
written and go. So it's a single binary,
very easy to deploy in a container or
as a static binary and do things with
it.
What I really love about Telegraf is that
it's database agnostic.
Even though it's by the team or the
company that produce InfluxDB,
Telegraf supports over 40 output plugins.
It can write to Kafka.
It can write to postgres.
It can write
Prometheus.
It can write to Cassandra. Like it doesn't
matter where you want to store your time
series metrics. Telegraf is still the right tool
for you or at least a tool for
you that could be the right tool for
you. And it supports some pretty cool architectures
based on some of the plugins it has
available.
We'll talk a little bit about that but
not too much as I'm gonna refer to
another talk that I've given before.
But some of the highlights of Telegraf that
I think are worth mentioning now, so they
so that it cannot you get a better
understanding of why I'm kind of evangelizing it
so much as that one,
it can write to multiple databases at the
same time.
So as you write your Telegraf configurations to
go and collect your metrics, you can write
them to InfluxDB,
Prometheus, Cassandra, Kafka, all of these places.
It gives you a level of resiliency and
redundancy that we don't normally have with the
monitoring and observability pipelines.
Another great feature of Telegraf is that it
supports remote configuration,
you can just rip your Telegraf configurations
over HTTP using you know, get hub raw
links using Amazon s three buckets and if
in the exposes that fail over HTTP
and Telegraf can consume them. It means you
can push your your configuration centrally and distribute
them to multiple edge locations and you can
really find that set up that works for
you.
What's also great is that by using Telegraf,
we got access to its ability to batch
and buffer the metrics. If any of your
output databases are down when it tries to
do a flush to that database, it can
store those metrics and memory to configure size
set by you
that understands
how much redundancy or resiliency you need for
those metrics.
Another really great thing is live health checks.
Telegraf has all of these metrics and its
memory.
What if we could do aggregations
on them
to understand if our application is healthy?
You know, we don't need to add a
slash health
endpoint to our applications
that have you know, have the code path
gets to and it returns to 200 we
assume our application is healthy. That's not always
the case. Our our health checks should be
more sophisticated.
Well, you can have Telegraf web these metrics
and memory performance aggregations,
look at the values and determine are my
applications returning
200 responses to the 99 percentile of our
customers within an accepted SLO?
If it's yes, return healthy.
If not, it can return not healthy and
that allows us to do things much more
dynamically and sophisticated.
Also Telegraf can be run as a serverless.
It has a flag called run once which
will boot up, collect the metrics, wait till
it's flushed them out and then exit. Really
really great if you wanna schedule it in
that fashion.
And finally Telegraf is composable.
It has plugins that allow us to work
over Unix domain sockets,
work over HTTP
and be able to take information out, spread
it back out to something else whether it
be HTTP or something else. Like all these
different flexibility and things that allow us to
just say, hey, I want to chain these
Telegrafs together to this other component and then
change Telegraf and other side of it. I
know that sounds very abstract, doesn't make a
lot of sense but
I will refer you to another talk that
I gave previously.
The Telegraf tool belt is available on YouTube
and it really breaks down how to use
Telegraf for these cloud native and distributed architectures.
I definitely recommend you check that out.
Alright. What are we gonna talk about today?
Well, I wanna talk about network monitoring
and Telegraf ships with plugins that allow us
to
really determine how much network monitoring we want
depending on our use case.
The first two are the most basic ones
that are net and netstat. Telegraph allows us
to collect those metrics and write them somewhere.
We'll take a quick look at that before
moving on to look in the SNMP and
SNMP traps and how we configure Telegraf to
work with those agents.
Then we'll very quickly take a look at
S flow and how that
can be collected by Telegraf.
And then I'm gonna finish with something a
little bit special and we'll get to that
at the end.
So
I don't know if this is a warning,
but I'm gonna try to move relatively quickly
through the configuration so that we can get
to the demo and see an action. So
don't worry
if after a few plug ins you're like,
I
can't fully grok it, I'm not seeing how
this works. Well there will be a demo
and the configs, So just
bear with me.
Plug in one
net.
This is of course very
easy to configure and enable has no configuration
at all.
We use TOML to configure Telegraf so we're
just using two square brackets to say hey
if we want to enable the net and
put plugin.
That's it. Job done.
Now the way this plugin works
is it has primarily support for Linux and
Unix based operating systems.
It does support Mac's
window support or limited support, but you will
get a few things.
It will monitor all of the up interfaces
on the host
except for loopback although you can't enable that
if you want
and it's gonna pull out basic networking statistics.
It's gonna understand how many bytes and packets
were sent and received on those interfaces.
It'll also be able to tell us how
many drops we had and how many of
the how many of packets had an error
state.
It does have one configuration option if you
want to use it to enable some SNMP
metrics from the proc fail system.
So you can start there
with or without that one option and you
will get an understanding
of the traffic leaving and coming into your
host.
We can then lay it on or add
or netstat plugin,
no surprises it doesn't take any configuration. Telegraf
is great this way, it doesn't want you
to write configuration unless you really need to,
so you'll notice a lot that you don't
really need to provide anything.
The next step plug in also reads from
flash proc
and it's gonna look using LSOF
to understand which files are open because everything
on Linux is a fail,
so it'll understand how many TCP connections we
have opened, the state they're in, whether they're
established, whether they're listening, whether they're closing and
we have some counts for UDPs because obviously
it's a state stateless
protocol.
Now you can get really far with this,
You
can
just understand
via standard deviations whether the machine has more
traffic than normal, less traffic than normal, more
errors than normal etcetera. You're gonna get a
really good understanding of the host and and
what's happening at a network level,
but we can do better.
So let's talk a little bit about SNMP.
Now
SNMP for those that are not familiar stands
for simple
network management protocol
and that always makes me laugh because at
first glance or even second glance or maybe
many glances.
It isn't actually that simple.
There's a lot going on and a lot
that you need to be able to translate
and understand to know what is happening when
you're using and consuming SNMP.
There are a few reasons
for the way that it was designed and
I think it's important to really just have
that as something that we understand when we're
talking about SNMP
is first this protocol was invented in the
eighties.
Right?
If we look at the hardware and in
the early eighties and late eighties,
We were shifting from eight bit word size
to 32.
It wasn't quite the standard yet.
The clock speeds on our CPUs ranged anywhere
from one to 25 with the average being
roughly 10 megahertz
and you could expect a machine back then
to probably have around 64
ks of RAM.
Now from a networking point of view, right,
the National Science Foundation,
the initial proposals of SNMP
had a backbone circuit of 50 kilobits.
Roughly the end user was getting 300 bits
per second based on the stats I could
find through Wikipedia and some other sources.
So when SNMP
was created had
these release really tight constraints with regards to
CPU
memory and network bandwidth
which means that you know we have a
lot of liberties today where we can transfer
vast amounts of data over HTTP
and text that is human readable
and get away with it. It wasn't really
the case in the eighties and this SNMP
was created in the early eighties, the first
public RFC was 88.
So things have changed but the protocol itself
hasn't changed too much although there is versions
one two and three.
So because of those constraints
we need to understand that SNMP as a
protocol
tries to really only transfer OIDs or numbers.
You can't read it and know what the
field is, you need to be able to
translate it. So as a prerequisite for the
Telegraf plugin you will need to your standard
SNMP tools available on the host that includes
SNMP walk and SNMP translate. It actually shell
execs out to SNMP translate to translate the
OIDs to something more understandable.
In order for that translation to work you
will need host that have the MIPS installed,
those can be fetched by most operating systems
with a simple command probably download dash MIPS
and
of course you're gonna need a lot of
persistence and I mean an awful lot of
persistence when you write SNMP configurations mapping
the fields that you need to enter your
TSDB,
you have to, you just have to be
patient and you have to really understand what
is going on. So you should be comfortable
using SNMP book and I'll show an example
of that on the demo.
Now
you can
configure this plugin
with nothing.
Not gonna get you very far but you
can and what happens when you configure it
with nothing is that Telegraf is going to
inject the whole inject the whole bunch of
defaults.
Those defaults are this agent is available in
local host. We assume you're gonna speak to
the agent there.
It will use version one by default, you
can go on to provide authentication by using
version three if you wish. It will assume
the community is public
and there are some intervals timers and retries
that can be configured, although you're probably gonna
get away at least in your experimental stage
using the default values.
And nothing's gonna happen. You're gonna run Telegraf
with this configuration and you're not gonna see
any metrics and that's because SNMP
has this whole table that we can walk
to fill metrics out and Telegraf is not
going to consume them all by default because
one thing databases don't like is large amounts
of arbitrary data
So we need to provide the configuration to
tell it what fields we care about from
the SNMP table.
So
pick the fields, get them into Telegraf configuration,
be comfortable debugging SNMP using SNMP walk, it
is an invaluable tool for putting these configurations
together
and whenever possible
steal prior art.
If you're going to get help you will
find many configurations many,
many people that are already monitoring the devices
that you want to monitor with SMMP and
that's not gonna change very often so you
can really get really far with this.
I also want to give a shout out
to a former colleague of mine Rob Cowart,
we worked together at Influx a couple of
years ago,
he was very
into network monitoring and has kept this repository
online all this time where SNMP,
InfluxSNMP
on his username.
It has configurations for all of the major
routers that you can hopefully
you're using within your network and your infrastructure
from you know Juniper to Ubiquiti etcetera so
these
directories actually contain telegraph configurations that map all
of the
OIDs to field names to store and set
up influx. It's an invaluable resource if this
is what you're trying to do.
Now we'll come back to SNMP in the
demo
but we may also want to have support
for SNMP traps. Now this is relatively new
in Telegraf, it was added within just the
last year but Telegraf can run
as a listener for those traps coming from
your SNMP agents.
What I would suggest is, well sorry, this
is the Wikipedia definition. The SNMP traps to
kind of and there the control a little
bit instead of you as the polar reaching
out to your SNMP agent and pulling your
metrics that you want on your regular interval.
You can actually have that SNMP agent send
messages
back down to you and you can listen
for them and consume them.
There are a couple of use cases for
that, we'll touch on that a little bit
but just know that Telegraf can receive those
and you can
can work with them relatively easily.
SM meter apps are configured by just enabling
the plug in and providing the port number
that we wish to listen on and then
the SMP
agent can send those traps to the listener.
Nice and simple
and of course we've also got the S
flow plugin for Telegraf
if you're not sure about S flow there's
this wonderful animation from the sflow.org website.
Basically what it is doing is it configures
via IP tables
a
sampling rate of all of your traffic which
will be written to the s flow agent.
That s flow agent can then pass it
on to one or more collectors in our
case we're gonna configure Telegraf to be that
collector.
And in order to be the collector we
enable the Sflow plugin and provide a port
number.
Again, Telegraf tries to keep this as simple
as possible. Thank you Telegraf.
Now there's one other thing that I wanna
talk about outside of Telegraf and that is
InfluxDB two and that it provides a very
convenient manifest sales
system for applying configurations and allowing us to
consume and reuse other people's configurations
and for today's demo I have used two
of these configurations,
very very easy. Now
anything that exists in InfluxDB two can be
configured through this manifest format that includes buckets,
Telegraf configurations for the remote configuration that we've
talked about earlier,
we can also provide dashboard users and organisations
and this can all very familiar if you're,
it will all feel very familiar if you
have used cube control in the past, right?
We cube control apply dash F and Flux
is influx apply dash F.
So let's go straight into the demo now.
Let's see if we can see how all
of these pieces of the puzzle connect together
to give us an understanding of what is
happening within
infrastructure.
Alright.
So what I have here is a Linux
machine running on Equinix metal and I have
Telegraf running in the background collecting
my network data through all of the plugins
that we just discussed.
The first thing I want to do was
pop into our Telegraf directory
and we'll list the files.
So what we have is SLO configured as
an input. SNMP,
SNMP traps. We're writing to InfluxDB
and to standard out and that just means
that it's
if I wanted to I could debug that
output from a standard file on a disc
or through journal D.
These configurations are very much exactly like I
showed
on the slides.
Our S flow plug in is configured only
with a service address.
Our s and m p trap.
Delete, delete, delete.
It's configured
with just a service address.
We have our inputs system
which has our network plugin listed here and
I've also got all the other basic system
monitoring stuff that I would want. CPU, disk,
disk IO, MEM, processes swap and another generic
system plugin.
And then the big skinny one, the SNMP
conf. Now well enabling
it is simple, we do have the field
mapping here.
So let's just have a quick look at
this and then I'll show you how we
get some of this information. So
if we scroll up, I have SNMPD
configured on this machine to expose system metrics.
And you can see this is exact configuration
from my slides. So I'm just pointing the
agent to local host with a community public
version one, so I'm not dealing with any
authentication and keeping this all relatively simple.
And then you can see we have a
lot of field definitions.
So we're just using the SNMP dot field
and put syntax, we give it a name
that we want to store inside of the
database
and then we represent or tell it which
OID maps to that field
and if we need to do any conversions
on data types, we can provide that as
well.
Now
this Telegraf configuration I got from a Telegraf
community template.
If I drop out of here and pop
open a new tab and type community templates,
or to spell templates.
Then we'll see there is this big massive
YAML file here and our Telegraf configuration is
in there towards the bottom.
If we go back to the community templates
repository,
you'll see there's a whole bunch here. Right?
There's not just the SNMP template, there's you
know, up, there's Linux system, there's many IO
MongoDB.
Hopefully that the software that you're using has
a template that you can apply.
However,
I also recommended that you get comfortable using
your debugging tools as an MP walk.
This tool is invaluable.
We specify the version, our community
and our agent.
And that will walk all the data that
we have now because I have the MIPs
installed on the system, we're not gonna see
the OIDs
on the left, we're gonna see something that
is more human readable.
If we scroll up,
you can just see fields that maybe I'm
interested in and monitoring.
Really really good tool
helps to be comfortable with it and these
same IDs on the left can be used
instead of the
configuration.
Now what does that look like?
Inside
of
InfluxDB.
Well, let's just refresh this. Make sure we've
got all our up to date information.
We can filter on the measurement that we're
interested in. So firstly, let's take a look
at SNMP.
You can see the load averages because we're
using SNMP for Linux system metrics. I doesn't
have access to any routers to be able
to get anything bit more interesting except my
printer and I didn't think you'd wanna see
me track the number of printed pages over
time because it doesn't fluctuate much.
But you can see here my load average
has come up and down over the last
one hour and I've actually left this running
I think for the last day. So you
can see something
weird happening here.
But
really great way to fetch metrics
and understand it.
We can also take a look at our
traps.
We click on this. Oh, I just have
to deselect them
and I hit go.
Just
refresh that. I'm not sure what happened there.
Let's try again. S and NP
trap. Oh and I need to look at
the last twelve hours. There we go.
We'll see that we have a trap that
has got some sort of field that is
modifying the sys uptime instance. Now traps
are events.
You cannot graph events,
right? They need to be aggregated.
However, InfluxDB allows us to escape that for
a moment and we can just use the
raw event data
And what we'll see here is that at
12:50,
a little over an hour and ten minutes
ago, I restarted SNMP.
And in fact if I do that again,
we should see that the SNMP agent sends
more traps to our listener.
No telegraph as configured with a batch and
a buffer and a flush interval.
I'm really hoping I have it set to
ten seconds but I cannot be entirely sure
but let's just hit go again
and there we go.
Now you can see here,
where's the time?
There we go. Fourteen o one and fourteen
o one, slightly different order but you can
see we have a notify shutdown and a
cold start. So those traps are being consumed
by
InfluxDB and the configuration for that is very
simple as well.
There we go. SNMPD.
Oh, wait. Because it's SNMPD.com.
And
we just add
a trap sync to local host for the
public community and Telegraf is listening on the
standard port number. So that just works nice
and simple.
Okay.
Let's keep going. Let's take a look at
S flow.
You'll see we have lots of things going
on here. Let's just quickly pull out a
couple, we'll hit go
and
the S flow stuff as also event based
data,
not ideal for viewing on a graph. However,
using InfluxDB templates,
we can apply those to our cluster get
dashboards but other people have built the aggregations
to visualize that but you can see here
we have all of these events of traffic
that has been sampled by IP tables. I've
done some
DNS stress testing on this machines. You're gonna
see a lot of lookups to eleven eleven,
the cloud flare DNS and
in fact we can just quickly trigger
some more. So we're gonna go into get
hub.
Let's do DNS stress
and this time I'm gonna use eight eight
eight eight.
And we'll just let that run for about
ten seconds to get some new s load
data into that. Now the reason I'm using
the DNS stress testing tool is just that
I need enough packets heading the network to
be sampled and show up in a database
running your traditional ping or DNS lookup may
not be enough for the sampling to kick
in.
Okay. So we're gonna leave that like that.
The next I wanna apply the InfluxDB templates.
So I have this direction. Now I could
use the HTTP URLs.
However, I did make a couple of modification
to these templates and just to show you
I'm going to open one up, know, are
very Kubernetes like you can see I've got
labels being applied here. I've got a variable
here. I've got some Telegraf configurations here which
I'm not actually using and there's dashboards further
up that I wouldn't bore you with right
now. However,
I can do an influx supply
dash F
S flow
and there's no auto complete I need to
get, I need to ask somebody to fix
that but first dashboards
there's nothing.
We apply this template, we get this nice
big list that tells us everything that's gonna
create within our InfluxDB server and we hit
go.
And I'm gonna do the same for SNMP.
YAML.
Oh,
that's great. I've got one YML and one
YAML.
And we set go. Now when I come
back over here,
we have dashboards
that I didn't write normal how to write
available
to me and I think that's fantastic.
So let's pop open our SLO source and
destination,
we can see traffic blurps here, this one
here was obviously me testing with the cloud
layer DNS and I think if we just
drop this down to five minutes. Yep. We're
gonna see those eight eight eight eight. Now
I know that's painful to read
but you can see the destination IP is
eight.
So we can see that network flow coming
through
and if we go to our SNMP system
monitoring again this dashboard knows that I have
SNMP running on the Linux host and it
knows it can read the system margin coming
from that. So I can see my system
uptime which is zero days.
I can see CPU utilization,
I'm barely touching this box memory allocation again
not really touching must.
We've got some CPU load, this will be
that DNS stress I just ran and we
can see the memory being freed when it
finished.
We've got some used memory claiming, know all
the basic stuff here and a little bit
of IO work.
So NVACDB templates are fantastic way to really
visualize that data especially from networking standpoint.
So that we don't need to understand those
queries and write them ourselves because sometimes they
can actually be quite challenging.
Alright. We should
showed SNMP as an MP trap and
S flow. Let's jump back to the slides.
So Telegraf and InfluxDB
really do provide a great way to monitor
network and traffic.
But I want to do a quick bonus
round before we finish.
Plug the problem with plugins
is they are opinionated by the person that
originally wrote the plugin.
To try and be as little configuration as
possible while giving you as much value but
in the eyes of that single person
and your use case may not be the
same as other people. You may want to
expand on that or provide new
metrics that aren't actually monitored.
And this is a networking track. So I
also want to talk about BPF because I
think we all like working with BPF to
one extent or another.
So how can
we use BPF web Telegraf to get metrics
into InfluxDB or any other time series database?
Well, there's this plugin relatively new in Telegraf
land that came out last year called Exec
D. Exec will allow Telegraf to manage the
run the running
of any arbitrary application on the machine and
handle fetching the metrics from its output and
storing them and its normal metric collection pipeline.
That means any language, any tool, bash, ruby,
rust, go you want to write as long
as you can spit out CSV or JSON,
lame protocol or any other supported format,
you can write your own plugins that Telegraf
will manage for you. And it is really,
really easy.
What I have here
is the IO visor BCC repository cloned on
this machine.
I call this repository because it has a
really great examples directory and in fact if
you go into the networking directory underneath examples,
you'll see a whole bunch of things as
I already has BPF scripts available.
I thought it would be cool using the
DNS matching script here.
If we could count
how many times domains are looked up using
this kernel trace.
So if I can't my Telegraf configuration,
you'll see I've just got the flush interval
set to five seconds so we can see
some data hopefully and close to real time.
I provide the command that I want to
run which in this case is just a
Python script with this DNS matching code and
I'm telling it I want to count all
the lookups for google.com.
I then can specify a signal that I
want to be able to handle so if
we want to be able to reload or
restart that process we can you know provide
the means to do that.
I've used JSON as most languages can already
output JSON, so you know Python is very
easy. I just tell Telegraf hey this application
will print out two standard out JSON documents
that we want to be able to parse.
We tell how to parse those documents so
that we'll have a time key that is
a Unix timestamp value and that there are
two other keys on that JSON document that
we want to store as tags so that
they are indexed.
That is the name of the domain that
we're trying to resolve and the type of
DNS lookup that we're doing. I then use
an aggregator plugin which allows us to and
real time and memory
take event based data like a DNS lookup,
something that cannot be graphed and build an
aggregation on it. So in this case it
is going to every two seconds count how
many requests were made to that domain and
then give me an aggregated account for that
window.
And instead of writing to InfluxDB, I'm only
gonna write this out to standard out.
Just means I can run Telegraf like so.
And in a few seconds, hopefully, we will
start to see some data come to the
terminal
right on queue.
Now the reason we're seeing data and I'm
not doing anything on this machine is I
also have DNS stress running in the background.
Looking up google.com and microsoft.com.
And we can see here we get
a lookups on google.com
quite a lot of times every two seconds.
I think that's 15,000 up to 30,000 down
here and we're not seeing that monitor microsoft.com
at all because it was not part of
our allow list.
However,
we can modify our Telegrafconf
and say, hey, you know what? We do
want to see microsoft.com
counts.
Like so.
And we rerun Telegraf And again, and hopefully
just a few seconds.
Oh
no.
Easy.
And then very simple demo.
We have
written a BPF trace,
had Telegraf manage the process
and parse the JSON output from our executive
plugin and store it
and FluxDB or in this case print to
the terminal.
Now you may be wondering what changes had
to be made to this repository for that
to work. Well, the only thing I really
had to do was add the type module,
remove any arbitrary print statements that aren't spitting
out the JSON that we wanna be able
to parse,
and then this application would just print all
the questions and answers to the terminal.
I modified it to do a loop and
then print out using an f formatted string,
a JSON document with accounts that I want.
The aggregator plugin
tallies them up every two seconds and we
get our metrics.
Couldn't be easier.
That's all I have for you today. I
hope based on what you've seen, you now
know that Telegraf is a really interesting, powerful
and fantastic application to be part of everyone's
monitoring and metric collection pipeline. It has support
for over 200 plugins, some really great networking
support for SNMP
traps, SLO and even BPF if you're willing
to write a little bit of code. I'm
happy to take any questions now. Thank you
for joining me and have a great day.